تشاهدين هذه السيده التي تحاول الافلات
بصعوبه
من الشوارع التي تشهد المواجهات بعد ان
بقيت عالقه
ومثلها العشره من ملحوصر داخل المحل
التجاريه التي لم تغلق ابوابها لحظه بدء
المواجهات عدد كبير من المحل التجاريه
اغلق ابوابه
المواجهه يبدو انها تتجدد هنا
المحتجون الغاضبون يردون على القنابل
المسيله للدموع التي تطلقها الشرطه
باتجاههم بقذف حجاره متوسطه وكبيره
ويقومون باشعال اكوام من النفايات يقطعون
بها جاده ستراسبور في الدائره العاشره
والاحياء والشوارع المتفرعه عنها هذه
الدائره العاشره للتذكير كانت احد اهداف
الهجمات التي سجلت في الثالث عشر من نظر
من العام 2015 في ذلك اليوم المشؤوم قتل
ارهابيون 130 شخصا وجرحوا اكثر من 400
اخرين
واليوم طبعا طبيعه الهجوم مختلفه تماما
اليوم يتعرض
اكراد مقيمون في فرنسا
لهجوم استهدف مركزا ثقافيه لهم وصالون
تصفيف للشعر مجاور لهذا المركز الحصيله
ثلاثه قتله وثلاثه جرحه